कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखे हिंदी में और नए
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज का एपिसोड
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है क्योंकि आज हम जर्मन
भाषा के मेरे खयाल में जो सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
उसे ज़ोर जो इंपॉर्टेंट वर्ड्स हैव अ हमार
सीखने वाले हैं वह मैंने अपने अनुभव से वह
लिए हैं और अगर आपको अगर वर्ड्स आते हैं
तो आप छोटे-छोटे जर्मन कन्वर्सेशन कर सकते
हैं यह मेरा विश्वास है अभी आप बोलोगे कि
टाइल्स वर्ड एक साथ हम कैसे करेंगे तो
आपको करने भी नहीं है आपको हर रोज सिर्फ
पांच या 10 वर्ड नौकरी पांच वर्ड कटिंग
प्रोग्राम बहुत डेडिकेटेड हो तो हर रोज पर
हर रोज को महत्व है हर रोज 10 वर्ड कीजिए
तो मैंने उसके लिए यह वीडियो भी ऐसे ही
बनाया है अगर आप वीडियो के किसी भी मिनट
में जाओगे आपको पांच यह पांच से सात वर्ष
तक मिलेगा आप किसी के किसी भी दिन कोई भी
एक ग्रुप कर लो उसमें सब है ना उन्हें
वर्ड्स है
अर्जेंट यूज है और कोई भी ग्रुप दूसरे गुट
पर डिपेंड नहीं है आप इनसे भी आओगे तो भी
आप सिमिलर भी ही पढ़ोगी तो हर रोज सिर्फ
पांच नेवर आपको सीखने हैं दो महीने में
आपको इशारे बढ़ाएंगे अगर 10 मिनट आप करोगे
हर रोज तो एक महीने में ही आने लगी
अच्छा ठीक है और दूसरी चीज में आलरेडी
देता हूं कि याद कैसे रखने का इस सिंपल
भेजो मुझे खुद यूजफुल है कि अगर फैंस है
विनय है तो आंखों के सामने टीवी 4a करना
चाहिए टीवी टीवी मतलब याद मत रखो या फिर
ट्यून ट्यून पहले तो दरवाजा आपकी आंखों के
सामने आना चाहिए वर्ष के लिए भी वर्ष के
लिए भी टाइम दिन बोलें टाइम्स अगर है तो
आपके आंखों के सामने प्रभुदेवा चाहिए जो
भी ब्रेंड जिंगल है तो लता मंगेशकर आनी
चाहिए तो क्या होगा कि आपको फिर कभी जिंगल
मतलब क्या यार रखने की जरूरत नहीं है अगर
यह क्लियर है तो हम तीन छोटी सी चीजें
देखते हैं और फिर हम वर्ड सीखना चालू
करेंगे सबसे पहले इंपॉर्टेंट मुझे बहुत
लोगों ने रिक्वेस्ट की कि वह प्रोनोउनसेशन
आप देवनागरी लिपि में या हिंदी में लिख कर
दो हाय या फिर स्पीडिल्य गिव नगरी में लिख
कर दो ना मैं यह करूंगा ना
कि आपको ऐसा करने के लिए कहूंगा अगर कि
मेरे हिसाब से यह बहुत गलत है अब राइटिंग
हमने इंग्लिश पैसे नहीं सीखा है राइट
ज्यादा से ज्यादा क्या होगा दस से बीस
परसेंट आप गलत होगी एक बार दो बार गलत
प्रभाव करोगे जैसे-जैसे आप उसका आधा चम्मच
कि आप करेक्शन कर लूंगी एक चीज गारंटी मैं
देता हूं इंग्लिश में जो पूरे तो अ नीचे
होता है वह डेफिनेटली जर्मन में नहीं
कि दूसरे इंपोर्टेंट चीज जो मैंने यहां पर
अगर आप देखोगे नॉर्म्स के लिए देर रात दास
यूज किया है पोस्टर नॉमिनेटिव मतलब जब मैं
बोलता हूं डाइरैक्ट वाटर तो इस जस्ट उसे
की फादर पुलिंग की है डीसी मोटर मगर
फीलिंग है और डांस के तहत बचत न्यूट्रल है
कि थिस कंपलीट की आदत टॉपिक है वह हमने
अलग पॉइंट्स में सीखा है आप उसमें वह देख
सकते हैं और तीसरी अगर इंपोर्टेंट चीज
जैसे हिंदी में भी एक वॉर्ड के अलग मीनिंग
होते हैं कल मतलब यह स्टाइल है भी होता है
कल मतलब टुमारो भी होता है वैसे जरूरत में
भी होते हैं हमने यह जो वर्ड लिए हैं उनके
लिए सबसे प्रचलित जोड़ते हैं और सबसे
क्लोज बारे में हिंदी में व हमने लिए
कि अगर यह क्लियर है तो शुरू करते हैं 250
पॉइंट है
मैं तो अपना शुरू करते हैं दिन दिन से देर
तक गंगटोक मतलब दिन भी रोक दी वह अ मतलब
सप्ताह सप्ताह तक खनन व कंडक्टर सैटरडे
संडे सेटरडे संडे दा यार यार मतलब वर्ड यह
नोट नॉट मतलब मां है
दूसरे दिन side-by-side मतलब समय या टाइम
धर्म और की अंधी दौड़ मार्किंग मतलब सुबह
इसलिए गुर्जर मौजूद थे दरगाह आफ मिटा ना
मिटा मतलब दोपहर और आधे आधे मिनट तक
प्रणाम
कि दिनांक दिनांक मतलब राह इसे उल्टे न अब
हम थोड़ी सी लिखने वाली चीजें बैकस्ट्रीट
बॉयज सिर्फ मतलब अपनी दबी कुली कुली मतलब
है
कि डर फ्लाइट स्टेट ने लाइट मतलब पेंसिल
आज तक भूख दासपुर मतलब किताब किताब आग और
घ्र घ्र मतलब नोट वो इसमें हम लिखते हैं
मैं अभी हम घर के निकट थोड़ी सी चीजें
देखते हैं
को सबसे पहले डू सदस्य उस मतलब मकान अभी
यहां पर स्पेलिंग इंग्लिश में एक्यूरेसी
कुछ भी लिखा था हाउस बोले थे यहां पर एच
एस यू वेयर हाऊस पुणे डिक्रीज करें देख
ट्यूर ट्यूर मतलब दरवाजा है
हु इज द फर्स्ट प्राइम मिनिस्टर डिस्पेंसर
मतलब खिड़की डूबा डूबा मतलब 66
इस दरगाह तक दरगाह तक सिंपल है गार्डन यह
बगीचा इधर राज्य यह करार जब मतलब गहरे अब
हम सारे जो रूम्स होते हैं उनके बारे में
बात करते हैं सबसे पहले दाईं म म मतलब रूम
से मतलब लिविंग रूम बैठक न धोएं बैडरूम
में भ्रमण करते हो बाथरूम
इस दिव्य दिव्य मतलब मैं सोई
कि digipay लेटर दिस टॉयलेट मतलब पायलट या
शौचालय अभी थोड़ी सी घर में जो चीजें होती
हैं वह देखते दबिश देकर डिश मतलब हुनर
वैस्टीज वैस्टीज मतलब खाने की टेबल पर
थे बेस्ट रूल 10 स्कूल मतलब कुर्सी
कि दास पेट दांत बट मतलब बिस्तर यह बैग
लुट-लुट मतलब दिया या लैंप
का दायित्व सौंपा मतलब सॉफ्ट अभी थोड़े
इलेक्ट्रॉनिक आइटम भी कहते हैं डेट्रॉयट
शहर डेट्रॉयट शहर मतलब ईद
कि दांत खिलाडीओ डिग्रियों मतलब रेडियो
अगेन जो बोला वही लिखा जो लिखता वही बोला
कि दास है नई दर हैंड ए मतलब मोबाइल फोन
लैपटॉप लैपटॉप कंप्यूटर और कंप्यूटर
है दैट यू विल स्ट्राइक प्यूरी शंख मतलब
रिसर्च ओं
कि दिमाग के मशीन अ दिवस मशीन वाशिंग मशीन
मैं अभी थोड़ी ऐसी चीजें देखते हैं कि जिस
पर हम ट्रैवल करते हैं गैस लोग धन सुख
मतलब ट्रेन जयपुर मतलब बगैर ही नाडु टो गो
टो मतलब कार दशरथ दशरथ उपलब्धि है जहां दो
कि दाणा सेओ रा दाणा मतलब साइकिल साइकिल
डांस मोटर मोटर मोटर साइकिल और डुब डुब
मतलब दिमाग प्ले
के रिश्ते देख लेते हैं हम सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट कौन से हैं डिमोट कर दी मोटर
मतलब मां
कि ने पाटन पाटन मतलब पिता आ
है दैट प्रोडक्ट ब्रूडर मतलब भाई डिश
मिस्टर दिवस पर मतलब बहन नेल्स ऑन सोन
बीटा
कि डॉक्टर डॉक्टर मतलब विधि
है दैट पॉइंट नेम रॉनित दोस्त दोस्त
दयुंगा दयुंगा लड़का ब्वॉय ब्वॉय गर्ल
लड़की की
कि दरमान निर्माण मतलब आदमी यह पुष्प दीप
पर्व श्रावण और अदरक डालकर मतलब बच्चा है
के दिन फिर ऑन टर्न ऑफ माउंटेन मतलब
रिश्तेदार
ए दिल एडिटर एडिटर मतलब हमारे माता-पिता
बैक रोज वाटर यह ग्रैंड फादर दादाजी
नानाजी यदि क्रॉस मोटर ग्रैंड मदर दादी म
डिकेड्स अधिकार जब मतलब बिल्ली एनिमल से
घर में बिल्ली कुत्ता है
मैं अभी खाने पीने की बात
और सबसे इंपोर्टेंट मैडम कौन-कौन से हैं
वह सूख कर झड़ सुनकर मतलब चीनी शुगर दाल
दाल मतलब नमक नमक
एक विशेष कोड व दिशा कोलाइडर मतलब चॉकलेट
चॉकलेट द गिवर यूज दिस गिव ऊ स मतलब
सब्जियां
एयरप्लेन मोड को ऑफ द ऑफ मतलब फल है
अरे भैंस देख लेते हैं तो बींस को क्या
बोलते हैं जब उन्हें दास गिरेंगे दाउद
तरंग मतलब प्रयोग ब्रिंग
को भी मेनू सदी मिर्च दूध
कि दास वस्त्र दास व कर पानी
एक व्यक्ति डिटेल मतलब नहीं कि केवल चार
कप कॉफी मतलब कॉफी
है अब इंजन मन की बात कर रहे हैं तो जर्मन
लोग जो खाते हैं वह चीजें भी चीज से बनती
हो देखना पड़ेगा तो वह भी देख सकते हैं
डांस क्लास डांस क्लास मतलब मां
के दाता आई मैं आई मतलब अंडा अंडा दबिश
देकर फिश आसान है न मछली बैक साइड देखा इस
चीनी
कि दास व रोड़ी मतलब रैंक यह पाव दरअसल
धैर्य मतलब सर यस अलार्म और देखिए एक
ऑप्शन मतलब कि अभी नींद हम जून में आएंगे
वह चीजें हैं अगला सिंपल फ्लावर
कि डिफ्लोरेशन मतलब बोतल देख सक दिशा सब
मतलब कब-कब धैर्य मतलब था लिए आप लें और
रिफ़िल मतलब चम्मच स्पून
जो अभी थोड़े हम अपने अवयव बॉडी पार्ट देख
लेते हैं तो सबसे पहले सबसे इंपोर्टेंट 10
गिर दिशा दास कि देश मतलब चेहरा
कि दिनांक दिनांक मतलब नौ गृह दशा और दिशा
और रन मतलब कहां है
को भी आओगे या नहीं आओगे इन मतलब आंखें
निर्माण मतलब मु दिखान डॉट बिहार का हाल
है
के दर्प उस दिन पुष्य मतलब पांव पैर बिहार
बिहार मतलब बॉल और जितेंद्र आदि मतलब दाणा
ओ
कि अब थोड़े कपड़े भी देख सकते हैं कि
होम्स दी हो सर मतलब पैंट ओं
कि दांत है म्यूट द फेम्ड मतलब शब्दार्थ
कि विष्णु हल्दी शिशु हां मतलब जूते
कि Bigg Boss कर दी जाकर मतलब सौम्य मुझे
देर में उन लोगों ने उन्हें वर मतलब
स्वेटर
है और राख रॉक मतलब कर दो
मैं अभी थोड़ी जगह सीख लेते हैं जहां जाते
हैं सबसे पहले सबसे इंपोर्टेंट दी शोल्डर
2016 मतलब विद्यालय स्कूल डांस ड्यूरो
ड्यूरो मतलब ऑफिस या कार्यालय देर बाद
लुटेरे बांहो मतलब रेलवे स्टेशन
का दर्प रूखापन दूर ऑप्शन मतलब एयरपोर्ट
या हवाई अड्डा डिफिकल्ट स्पेलर उस हल टेलर
बस करने की जगह बस स्टॉप धर्माचार
धर्माचार मार्किट या zsr circumcision
मतलब और दिव्य दिव्य मतलब पुस्तकालय लाइक
थिस
यहां पर थोड़े से प्रोफैशंस भी देख लेते
हैं
कि वे राख मैं आज मतलब होकर नैहर चल जैब
नैहर मतलब अध्यापक और जैसा कि हमने पहले
भी देखा था कि अगर male है अगर पुरुष है
कोलर स्त्री है तो लहर रवींद्र लाइन लगाना
होता है सब जगह डर इंजीनियर न इंडियन ऑयल
मतलब इंजीनियर पावर अ पावर मतलब किसान है
के दफ्तर दिस फ्रॉम मतलब हाउसवाइफ ऑयल या
अग्रणी बैंक कुंडल कुंडल मतलब कस्टमर
कस्टमर या ग्राहक
को दरकिनार कर केवल न मतलब वेटर वेटर
मैं अभी आपको थोड़े से एडवर्स बताता हूं
जो कि हर जगह लगेंगे एवरी स्मॉल वर्ड्स बट
वेरी यूजफुल लेते हैं मुंह 9 मतलब ओनली
लिए केवल यह मतलब पत्ते की मिठास मतलब
थोड़ा थोड़ा सा विटामिन सुजाण मतलब स्कूल
जप तप के पीछे तुरंत
कि अलग-अलग मतलब ऑल या सभी तब यस-यस मतलब
नाव या अभी ठीक है तो अभी और वह सब थोड़ा
सा half-way मार्क के आगे आ गए हैं तो अभी
हम वर्ग सीखेंगे इनमें से कुछ और अपने
पहले भी देखे थे अगर आपने उस टाइम नहीं
क्योंकि तो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं अभी हम उसका
सुपर सेट देखेंगे मतलब थोड़े पहले के भी
और थोड़े एक्स्ट्रा
मैं पहले सबसे इंपोर्टेंट मंथ्स माखन माखन
मतलब करना
ए वूमेन वह नल मतलब कहीं पर रहना इस वो
नाइन उस है
आ जे एन गहन मतलब हुआ था कोमल कोमल मतलब
आना लाइफ इन लॉ फर्म अब सोना बाढ़ बाढ़
मतलब VoLTE का ऑप्शन मतलब कुछ तो मकान
एक्सेल खाना पीना खाना ले लें मतलब पढ़ना
प्रशन प्रशन मतलब बोलना वेब उज्जैन मतलब
दिखना युक्त अंजुमन मतलब कुछ तो ढूंढना
इस पावन मतलब पार मतलब गाड़ी चलाना चलाना
है
है और राइफल मतलब राइफल मतलब यात्रा करना
यहां पर जाना ट्रैवल ओं
आज तक पर तर्पण मतलब किसी से मिलना तर्पण
टो मीट संबोधित करेंगे घरलू सिंपल ब्रिंग
अलांग क्रॉनिक रावण पूछना मतलब है मतलब
किसी की मदद करना और मतलब कोई चीज शुरू कर
दो
ई विल ट्री लर्न मतलब खेलना स्कूल क्रिकेट
टेंशन टेंशन मत वक्त नाचना दुश्मन दुश्मन
मतलब तैरना न
के दिन थिंगल मतलब गाना
ए आई एल आई एन लोटन मतलब किसी को इनविटेशन
देना आमंत्रित करना
है लीवर लीवर मतलब प्यार करना है
है लखन लखन मतलब हंसना विद एजुकेशन मतलब
बैठना है
हैं अरमान अरमान का ख्याल ऑन करना चालू
करने और समर्पण और समर्पण बंद कर दो
कि जीवन के बदले ना मेमन ने मल लेना
डेक्कन क्रॉनिकल सोचना
का बर्थडे है
तो पड़ते हैं मतलब समझना रावण ब्राह्मण
मतलब किसी चीज की जरुरत हो ना किसी चीज़
की ज़रूरत हो ना वेस्टर्न ऑस्ट्रेलियन
मतलब ऑर्डर करना कोई आर्डर कर मंगवाना
कि लेबनान लेबनान एकदम इजी है ठीक ना
हेलो हाय राटन हाय रतन मतलब शादी करना
यो यो और यौवन मतलब सुन्न
यह सिलाई विपन शर्मा एवं मतलब लिखना लाइफ
इन ए
में लाखों ओपन मतलब तोडना या भंग ना
एक रिमाइंडर मेडल कोई चीज काटना
कि अग्रेशन एग्रेशन मतलब भूल जाएगा
MP3 न ओरिजिनल मतलब ज्यादा याद करना भेजो
कल किसी को मिलने जाना भेजो कल टो विजिट
थे फायर फायर कोई चीज सेलिब्रेट करना और
उसका जश्न
ईपॉक्सी वाटर वाटर मतलब राह देखना
अपने मित्र मतलब पिज्जा रत्ना और किन्नर
मतलबी जाएगा इस तन और मन दोनों के अर्थों
में थोड़ा सा फर्क है वह आप आगे जाकर
चरणों की असली लिसन लिसन बंद करना एवं
विपणन फाइनल खोल दो
कि बैंगन बैंगन मतलब सोचना सोचना
की व्यवस्था लंद साइलेंट मतलब पैसे दे
देना बुक्तान कर देना
और पैर कूपन पर कफन मतलब छैना काफी सॉफ्ट
कॉटन मतलब खरीदना जहानगंज साधन मतलब कुछ
कहना
की रिपोर्ट पर पैर झरोखन तै राजू खन मतलब
टूट राय कोशिश करना
कि इंटरनैशनल कांट्रेक्टर मतलब सीखाना
ध्रुवण डक्कन इस पुश दबाना सफेद सफेद मतलब
ड्रा खींचना अंत में सबसे इंपोर्टेंट बटन
बटन मतलब काम करना
मैं अभी हम हफ्ते के दिन लगते ओके एकदम
सिंपल है अगर आप देखोगे एकदम सिंपल है
मेघनाद को मोंटा मोंटा
कि सोमवार सोमवार डिफ़ाल्ट मतलब ट्यूसडे
मंगलवार मिनट वर्क परमिट वर्क मतलब ए
लिटिल बिट वॉक ऑफ द स्टार डू मतलब मतलब
स्कूल में का मतलब साइड मतलब शनिवार
क्वांटम मतलब स्कूल वेरी सिमिलर टो थे तो
महीने तक यह सारे एक महीने महीने है
है तो मिलते हैं उनको मैं उनको हिंदी में
नहीं लूंगा फिर भी तक उपचार देखो एक बार
तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा मीनिंग तो एकदम
सिंपल है या नवाब या न फैब्रिक रॉ है
यह क्रॉस मैं और मैं अप्रैल तरफ माय माय
मैं जो बोल रहा हूं वही लिख ना यूनी यूनी
यूनी यूनी आफ उस हैव उस व्यक्ति गंभीर व
टो वेयर टो बे ए five-member नवंबर को अब
हम मौसम मौसम इसको बोलते हैं सिस्टम
थे फेस्टिवल तो कौन-कौन से होते हैं जो
बसंत होती है वह है फ्यूलिंग धैर्य
ड्यूरिंग हेर ड्यूरिंग द एग्जामनर गर्मी
ड्रॉप ड्रॉप मतलब पतझड़ और प्रिंटर विंटर
मतलब क्या है
है अब इसके साथ मैं उन पांच इंपोर्टेंट
वर्ल्ड बताता हूं जो आपको हमेशा लगेंगे
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है आपका जन्मदिन देर के
स्पोर्ट्स दर के बूटस्ट्रैप इन जन्मदिवस
दर्ज कर लुटेरों की छुट्टियां छुट्टियां
अरे डॉक्टर मतलब मतलब कल टुमारो वाला
डायरेक्टर सब्सक्राइब कर
को हॉस्पिटल गेस्टर ओके अब हम रंग दे रंग
सिंपल कुछ हैं कुछ थोड़े से लेकर सबसे
पहले रोड रोड मतलब लाल गैलरी गैलरी मतलब
ब्लाउज ब्लाउज मतलब नीलम
यह वाइट वाइट मतलब हफ्ते शुमार स्वर्ग
मतलब काल और ग्रहों ग्राम मतलब ग्रेग
वैज्ञानिक मतलब हरा ग्रीन बुलेट बुलेट
मतलब आयरलैंड आयरलैंड एंग्री रोज-रोज मतलब
पिंक रोज टेंपल रन और यहां पर आओ ब्राउन
मतलब और अगर आपको अगर बोलना है वहीं गहरा
हरा है यह कह रहा है कि डार्क ग्रीन है तो
उनके लाइट घ्र घ्र और पांच इंप्रूव वो
मतलब कोई नया मतलब यह 20
कोट 40 पर सेंट यह सब ऑफर वैष्णो देवी
वैष्णो मतलब महाराज बिल बिल देर उपयोग
डुबो मतलब प्ले लिस्ट
है और दीप्ति तरफ मतलब शैलियां सीढ़ियां
है और अंत में हम जाएंगे सारे विशेषज्ञ
एटीट्यूड और एडवांस को ठीक है तो सबसे
पहले हम सिंपल वाला नोएडा नोएडा मतलब नया
ताल आदि का मतलब पुराना कुल घूंट मतलब
अच्छा फ्लेवर स्नैक्स मतलब बूरा खराब क्रम
क्रम मतलब बीमा मतलब गरम-गरम का मतलब गुरु
गुरु बड़ा मतलब छोटा सा
थे ब्यूटी टिप्स मतलब हैप्पी कुछ तरफ और
इस तरह वृक्ष मतलब पैर दांव क्षण-क्षण
मतलब सुंदर ब्यूटीफुल
कि हैप्पी एक्ट्रेस मतलब अगली चैनल असली
मतलब तेल फास्ट लांग लांग मतलब लोग धीरे
मतलब अ
कि इस वीर मींस मतलब हार्ड
कल शाम जानता मतलब कोमल मुलायम स्व-स्वर
मतलब कठिन या कठोर स्त्रियों प्रयोग मतलब
शीघ्र आर्मी पेस्ट मतलब से ले लो
कि कोई चीज फ्रेश है ब्रश बादाम है और उमर
उमर मतलब हमेशा ऑल वे नीड मतलब नेवर कबीर
ने और मंच मंच मंच मतलब कभी कल शाम गए तो
आज हमने ढाई सौ नए जर्मन वर्ड्स सीख सकें
तो जैसे मैंने कहा हर रोज सिर्फ 5 से 10
स्वर्ण अगर आप करोगे तो 1 से 2 महीने में
आपको यह आने लगेंगे दूसरी चीज यह जब आप यह
वर्ड्स करोगे तो आंखों के सामने लाने की
कोशिश करना तो आप उनको मुगलों के नहीं और
अगर आपने यह वर्ष की है और अब तक हमने जो
ग्रामर किया है वह घर कंसेप्ट के क्लियर
होंगे तो आप एक से दो महीनों में स्माल
जर्मन और श्रम करने लगे यह मेरा विश्वास
है
तो फिर मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद